dans ce contexte de pandémie de nombreux
français se plaignent de la privation de
liberté individuelle et certains avocats
également l'on remarqué c'est pourquoi
je vais à la rencontre aujourd'hui de
jean marc andré avocat à versailles
ancien bâtonnier de versailles bonjour m
comment allez vous non merci certains
français se plaignent on a pu le voir
encore une fois alors des convois de la
liberté et vous ça vous fait réagir ah
ben je pense que le mouvement du convoi
de la liberté dans le prolongement de ce
que nous vivons depuis bientôt deux ans
c'est à dire qu'à un moment les gens se
sont réveillés ont vu qu'il y avait du
mensonge sur mensonge que les choses ce
qu'on nous vantait de sanitaires
n'étaient pas vraiment sanitaire qu'il y
avait quand même un marqueur politique
voire plusieurs marqueurs politiques
dans tout ce qu'on a subi tant qu'homme
de loi vous vous intéressez aussi au
respect du droit oui complètement c'est
à dire que la loi du 5 août suite aux
annonces du président de la république
le 12 juillet ont été les prémices de ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le fait que
les français sont privés de leur liberté
naturelle leurs libertés fondamentales
de se déplacer d'aller et venir de
pouvoir avoir une vie la plus normale
possible
alors que dans le même temps aucune loi
n'impose la vaccination obligatoire donc
on est arrivés dans un système de droit
où on prive des citoyens de droits
fondamentaux je rappelle que les hommes
naissent et demeurent libres et égaux en
droits alors que pourtant il ne viole
aucune loi qui ne commettent strictement
aucune infraction
que ça vous a donné envie de vous
mobiliser a complètement mais je me suis
sentie très seule et j'attendais
naïvement peut-être mais j'attendais
parce que la profession d'avocat si on
ne bouge pas lorsqu'il ya une atteinte
aux libertés même infime soit elle pas
si nous ne bougeons pas personne ne
bougera alors je me suis dit il va
prendre le taureau par les cornes on va
créer un groupe de travail ad hoc
seulement barreaux avec des confrères
qui partagent la même vision que moi ça
a permis déjà de sortir de cette
solitude pour revenir on convoi de la
liberté c'est ça aussi c'est un permis
de prendre conscience aux gens qu'on
n'était pas des pestiférés parce qu'on
n'était pas vaccinée ou parce qu'on
n'avait pas un schéma vaccinal complet
aussi puisque comme j'aime le dire les
vaccinés d'aujourd'hui sont les loups
vacciner de demain et on sait très bien
que le 15 février beaucoup vont perdre
leur passé vaccinale donc voilà on a
créé ce groupe de travail ont réfléchi
sur les textes parce que avocats comme
magistrat
ce sont des textes nouveaux qu'il a
fallu intégrer alors aujourd'hui maître
vous défendez des personnes qui hier ont
subi les restrictions au premier chef
leur travail puisque certains
malheureusement ne sont pas licenciés
puisque la loi ne le prévoit pas mais
sont suspendus ce qui finalement est une
solution encore pire pour eux puisque
c'est sans délai ils ne savent pas
jusqu'à quand ils n'ont pas de revenus
et après effectivement c'est pour eux la
perte de 2 to lors de tous leurs espoirs
parce que finalement il va falloir
trouver un autre travail et sans être
indemnisées par pôle emploi puisqu'il
n'y a pas de chômage puisque c'est une
suspension du contrat de travail
comment la justice réagit-elle dans ces
cas là parce que tous n'ont pas gain de
cause wheeler pour nous avocats entre
guillemets de terrain quand on n'est pas
dans le conseil constitutionnel le
conseil d'état mais devant les premiers
juges on sait que c'est très difficile
parce qu'il faut amener les dossiers
sans démons sans essayer de faire
comprendre que c'est un combat politique
ce n'est pas un combat politique c'est
un combat juridique et c'est aussi très
compliqué pour les magistrats quel qu'il
soit d'appréhender de juger ce genre de
contentieux et de dossiers parce que
bien évidemment il ya leur propre
ressenti par rapport à la vaccination
qui chez eux comme chez tout le monde
prend une place énorme puisque à travers
eux c'est leur famille c'est leur
enfance et leurs parents leurs grands
parents qu'ils ont forcément une idée
une conception par rapport à la
vaccination au pas par rapport à la
suspension des personnels ou des
personnes qui viennent devant eux donc
c'est difficile de garder une certaine
forme d'objectivité dans le dossier mais
certains y arrivent on y arrive est ce
que la parole politique à la contribuent
à alimenter ce clivage selon vous abel a
alimenté parce qu'en fait la parole
politique aujourd'hui est devenue la
source de droit voire la règle de droit
c'est-à-dire que dès le 12 juillet les
gens étaient persuadés alors que la loi
n'était pas encore voté que les
restrictions étaient mises en place que
le pass and i ter été mis en place alors
que rien n'ait été voté et c'est ça qui
est aujourd'hui compliqué c'est à dire
que on écoute la parole 10 min sur la
parole du président de la république
dont vous rêvez toute puissance du
politique et finalement le législatif
passe au second plan et malheureusement
les débats que nous avons eus à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat n'ont
pas été à la hauteur de nos attentes on
voit bien que les amendements finalement
n'ont pas été discutés comme il l'aurait
dû être tout a été fait
j'allais dire dans un délai très court
très rapide très contraint toujours sur
des périodes de vacances on qu'on prenne
le temps de se poser voilà je pense
qu'on a été trop loin et qu'il est temps
aujourd'hui que tout cela cesse mais sur
des conditions qui seront effectivement
à redéfinir et avoir sur un plan
politique et ça je pense que ce sera le
travail de la nouvelle assemblée qui
sera élu au printemps prochain